chances are you have heard of steph and
his brother seth curry while there's a
new set of superstar brothers that could
make their mark on the nba next season
evan mobley he's already leading league
he's in his first year with the
cleveland cavaliers after playing for
usc well his brother isaiah continues to
be a force for the trojans leading the
team into this year's ncaa tournament
thank you very much our carter evans
talked with the brothers and their dad
their dad by the way is a coach at usc
they spoke about march madness growing
up in a basketball family and how their
sibling rivalry has evolved into
brotherly love
if you don't know the name evan mobley
yet where have you been drafted third
overall last summer the california
native has been tearing it up for
cleveland this season and is hotly
tipped to be named rookie of the year he
owes a lot of it to his alma mater usc
and to these two eric and isaiah mobley
evans dan and older brother have been a
huge part of his growth what was it like
growing up in a basketball obsessed
family basketball was just always around
always on tv
always talking about basketball so it
was all natural for us
we just came in and
really just been around it for our whole
lives ready ready ready ready here we go
eric mobley is an assistant coach at usc
and isaiah is arguably the trojan star
player now that his 20 year old six foot
11 younger brother is in the nba the two
had a profound impact on the cavs phenom
both on and off the court with coach
mobley pushing his sons to test their
limits we would go to la fitness and we
play open gym no you're going to get out
there and play with adults they would
take them on their wing so i had a
village of
good mind basketball minds to help these
guys through the whole process so been
awesome
do you like having him as a coach oh
yeah i do um you're not just saying that
no because he's gonna watch this yeah
and the basketball connection doesn't
end with the men in the family mom
nicole also played high school ball and
isn't afraid to coach from the sidelines
yeah she's like the glue um
of our family i always can hear her she
doesn't yell at us anymore but like when
we're on the way up she always say like
someone shoots
rebound she's yelled all the time and so
i credit that definitely to her mom is
currently based in cleveland helping her
20 year old nba star son adjust a living
so far away from home basketball brought
your family together basketball built
your family and now it's split it apart
it's for a good cause so i'm not mad my
mom she makes it out here to a lot of
the big games and stuff yeah it has torn
support but i feel like it's brought us
closer in terms of relationship
christmas last year was marred by covid
the family had to meet on zoom but gifts
were exchanged and open in front of the
computer so he got your nice gift this
year yeah yeah and i was able to get him
something nice too and so like that was
like super cool and we got our parents
some cool stuff as well so it was a
wonderful christmas even though we were
apart yeah it's nice when you grow up
and you're able to like
do really nice things for the people you
love no definitely that's you right
there hobie including in isaiah's case
this sweet ride from his younger
superstar brother for his birthday
isaiah also entered the draft last
summer but at the last minute decided to
put in another year at usc to improve
his game a mature decision for a young
athlete and i was just like on the
borderline i just didn't know but it
allowed me to grow and get a lot better
and so at the end of the day i feel like
i made the right decision evan and
isaiah have a close bond from playing in
the backyard as kids to high school and
college teams early on the brothers were
extremely competitive their night and
day they would sometimes get into a
little scuffle
and i had to run out there and
break them up but they would get their
one-on-one battles and sometimes
my wife and say why let them let them go
let them go
let them work it out but there was some
tough battles back there but at the end
of the day the two have an unbreakable
connection forged over a lifetime of
playing basketball together you miss it
at all playing with him
uh yeah for sure yeah he's my brother so
i definitely miss uh playing with him
but um
that time has passed and maybe in the
future uh he can come in and play we can
play together and while evan takes on
the nba's finest older brother isaiah is
leading the trojans to another
phenomenal year expectations are high
that the team will surpass even the
elite eight stage which the mobley
brothers propelled them to last season
he may be a couple of thousand miles
away in ohio but evan mobley is with his
family in spirit i'll probably be
watching every game um i can for sure
and
probably calling isaiah or my dad or
whatever um just talking to them what
they thought really just enjoying the
whole entire march madness coming up
wow love it what a great family
oh i like that i like everything about
that story carter evans i love that mom
went to work with her son yeah to help
him get adjusted yeah i like how he also
said mom she don't yell at me as much
anymore but she should be on the
sideline rebound
anymore is doing a lot of work in that
sense very revealing and that's one way
to recruit a heck of a team you know
have your own children play do you think
would be hard to have your dad coach you
for sure i you know in high school when
i played football there was a
coach who his son was on the football
team i wouldn't have liked it he used to
get he used to scream at this poor kid
like and i would wonder what is it
what's the dinner table conversation
yeah exactly there's no separation
a special bond yeah oh boy